hallo liebe bild zuschauer sie haben
sich meine oster promis wirklich
verdient und die kommen jetzt und was
dürfen wir dieses osterfest nicht
vergessen händewaschen ja und
sonnenbrille hasta la vista baby bett
und modisch gesehen geht man dieses
ostern nur sinn geht man dieses ostern
im dialog heißt erstens sie werfen sich
in schale
dann machen sie striptease heißt sie
sind dann wie aus dem ei gepellt und
wenn sie dann am spiegel vorbeigehen
müssen sie wohl wahrscheinlich zu geben
es war wohl doch nicht das gelbe vom ei
das gelbe vom ei ist übrigens der
kirchenbesuch von desirée nick ja nicht
alleine die kirche ich nehme diesmal
claudia rath mit ja
das gibt gibt es dann sogar im fernsehen
wenn wir da stehen vorm altar promis
unter psalmen und wenn die auch noch aus
ihrem rausch auf aachener daran also war
eine auferstehung
so und jetzt noch vielleicht ein
osterlied otto waalkes
ja ich hab in österreich verliehen das
fängt mit anja i believe i can fly ich
glaub ich machte fliege oder vielleicht
die oster gedicht von heinz erhardt
hasen nicht kassen tragen zur osterfeier
auf dem rücken
dicke eier nicht nur hasen die bei
hefner wohnen nicht die tragen vorne
auch melonen und das war frauenfeindlich
aber vielleicht nur ein schlusswort von
ihm von udo lindenberg der trinkt seiner
eier nämlich aus dem glas wir wollen
immer schön alle kirchen und so happy es
seien keine panischen ich trinke auf ex
gleich zweimal auf die empore auf die ex
von pendlern
ich bring deinen und dann gibt es auch
ganz mekka dein dünnschiss schmeckt echt
lecker so aber ich möchte auch noch was
sagen bleiben sie gesund bleiben sie zu
hause und wenn sie wie ich zur
risikogruppe gehören dann behalten sie
nicht nur ihren mut sondern auch ihren
hut und ihre zähne sonst müssen sie noch
nach was anderem suchen also bleiben sie
gesund am besten 30 vor ostern so und
jetzt kommt noch dass hier
nein nicht einmal sondern mir ausmalen
was die kanzlerin gerade so macht mir
geht es gerade ausgezeichnet oder sagen
wir er gezeichnet vor allem im gesicht
und wo bleibt eigentlich ostern werden
sie mich fragen und hier dürfte ich mal
kurz ein geheimnis sie sehen es ja
ostern ist im anzug also in allen
treiben sie es bunt und lassen sie sich
ihre gute laune nicht verderben
nicht mal von mir